Welcome to the Unit 2 office hours.
One of the first questions I'd like to address deals with the Ply library
that we're using under the hood for this class
to help us out with lexing and parsing.
In the lectures we talked about how to write down a token definition.
You define a function t_something--like a number--
and then you'd write out the regular expression--0 through 9-plus.
Then you might do a little work modifying the token value--
maybe converting it from a string to an integer.
Then eventually you return the token.
The basic question from students is how does that work? What's going on?
After you write down a number of these token definitions,
there is a library behind the scenes--part of the grading scripts that we're using,
but also available for you to download if you'd like to try it out on your own--
that gathers up all of your token definitions.
One way to do this is using a technique called "reflection,"
which actually sounds very philosophical but is a way for a computer program
to look at itself and all of it's own capabilities.
In essence, our Python program asks, has anyone defined any functions recently
that start with t_?
If so, the next thing we have to do is get that regular expression out of them.
It turns out that Python functions allow you to write documentation or a brief explanation
at the beginning of any function. This is sometimes a good software engineering practice.
Our Python parsing library and our Python lexing library reuse this power.
We're writing down this regular expression, and the library is treating it
as if it were documentation.
We use that to get access to the regular expressions you've written down.
So step one: you write down a bunch of these token definitions.
Then we look--using reflection, for example--to find all of them.
Step two: we go through all of them and ask, do they have any strings at the beginning-
anything that looks like documentation. The answer is yes.
But for us it's not documentation. It's a regular expression specification.
The next thing to do is convert each of those regular expressions to a finite state machine.
Now, I hinted at this in class. Didn't give a full, formal proof on how to do it.
But it turns out that every one of the regular expressions--plus, star, disjunction, concatenation--
can be written out in a finite state machine.
For every regular expression there is at least one--and in fact, typically, infinitely many--
finite state machines that accept exactly the same language.
We'll just apply that conversion in the background.
But if you have a bunch of different token definitions--one for number, one for string,
one for some keywords in your language like "if," "then," or "else"--
we're going to end up with a bunch of different finite state machines.
Now we have to combine them all together.
If you're willing to humor me with nondeterministic finite state machines,
we could actually do that just by putting a special state at the beginning--
a special new start state--and having an epsilon transition
go to the beginning of each of our old states.
We'll glue them all together into sort of a Frankenstein's monster--
an amalgamation of everything we've looked at.
We're almost done except that it's not enough for a lexer to know this string is a token.
You have to know which one it is.
A real life lexer will have one more bit of information that we didn't talk about in class.
A state isn't just an accepting state, it's an accepting state with a little label.
If you accept, here it was a string.
If you accept here in this over there, it was the token then.
If you accept in this state down here, it's a number.
Instead of just known what the accepting states are,
we need to know what the accepting states are
and what token each one corresponds to.
All right. You did all your token definitions. We found them all.
Each one had a regular expression. We found that.
We converted each of those down into finite state machines.
We joined them all together. We labeled all the accepting states.
Now we represent that big finite state machine internally as edges.
This is sometimes formally called a transition table,
but it's just like the edges in coding that we used in class.
Now when it comes time to actually do lexing--to break a string down into
into important words and tokens--you just feed the characters of the string
one at a time into that big finite state machine.
It's exactly the same as the FSM sim procedure we went over in class.
It's just that their finite state machine is much bigger.
In fact, the FSM sim code that we wrote would work just as well,
even on bigger finite state machines.
I just didn't show it because they're harder to draw on screen.
Under the hood, this library is basically just doing a bunch
of grungy details, chores, busy work in the background.
We did exercises with one or two regular expression definitions.
The library gathers them all up together in one place.
You're already familiar with all of the key concepts in making a lexical analysis library.
The library just does a lot of the busy work for you. And that's the explanation.